so continuing our discussion on blue
Marvel we pick back up with Adam
Brashear during his first encounter with
Tony Stark Reed Richards and Hank Pym
but we also get a little more insight
into the history of his character and
the answer to the question of how he
gained his powers
so the story initially opens with Adam
Brashear and amphibious naval base
little creek in North Carolina now
something I'd like to point out here is
that in real life this Naval Base is
actually in Norfolk Virginia and deals
with offensive naval operations and
deploying soldiers overseas and into
hostile shores but the basis behind
Griffo bringing us as part of the story
is to focus on the history of Adam
Brashear and Connor Sims the ante man
what we learn here is that contrary to
previous depictions of white Americans
and the story up to this point not
everyone was racist during Adams time
prior to becoming the blue marvel in
this instance Adam was dealing with some
racist members of the Navy and where
previously he had remained hands-off
rather than facing dishonorable
discharge for conduct unbecoming of an
officer by way of fighting he along with
Connor Sims finally fought back and gave
the soldiers a lesson in humility now
transitioning to the present-day we join
Adam Brashear alongside Tony Stark Reed
Richards and Hank Penn aboard the shield
Helicarrier above New York something I'd
like to mention here is that we're I'm
normally straightforward on what I like
and dislike about a section of a story
in comics in this instance I'm actually
on the fence here the reason why is that
with Adam Brashear arriving on board the
Helicarrier start extends an olive
branch of friendship to Bashir by
offering a formal apology on behalf of
the United States and the President
himself would like to formally welcome
blue Marvel back to the superhero
landscape however Brashear doesn't
really want to hear it and where he
states that his intention is to focus on
the here and now by providing the group
with his knowledge of anti man to be
quite frank I don't think this was the
right road to take now this is something
that we'll get further into here in a
second but at the moment the
conversation shifts is focused to an T
man himself according to read the issue
that they face is that an T man is
wildly powerful more so than any one of
the Avengers have ever faced before now
to be clear this does not mean that the
anti man is the most powerful being in
existence cosmic entities like Galactus
and others are still far beyond anything
that an T man is capable of it's simply
that within the context of earth-based
villains none of the Avengers have
fought anyone like this before
something else that Grebo does here is
provide us with an understanding of just
how intelligent Adam Bashir is and
saying that he knows his way around a
science lab but that he also knows the
exact
in terms of how auntie man's powers work
and the reason for this comes in the
form of brashears backstory
what we're told is that at some point
during the careers of himself an auntie
man Connor Simms had become part of Army
Intelligence
while Beshear worked on a project
involving harnessing the power of
antimatter as a source of energy well
the military had intended to weaponize
this power before it was released to the
general public for other applications at
some point and for reasons unknown the
experiment went awry bathing both Adam
Brashear and Connor Sims and antimatter
energy where Simms was able to pull
Russia from the wreckage Simms appeared
to have succumb to the energy and was
completely obliterated
as a result Connor Sims became the anti
man while Brashear became the blue
Marvel now what curva was doing here is
providing us with the basis behind blue
marvel's power but to be honest he
doesn't really do the best job
explaining exactly what Brashear is
capable of in clear and simple terms
having said that the best way to think
of blue Marvel is that he is a less
powerful version of Franklin Richards
where Franklin can manipulate all matter
in existence regardless of whether it be
normal matter or antimatter Anna
Brashear is powered by and can only
manipulate antimatter what this means is
that aperture were to enter the negative
zone he would be godlike in terms of his
ability to manipulate and control all
things within that space but within the
normal universe he's capable of
incredible strength speed and durability
but also has enhanced senses and like at
the same time the anti man is the same
way but the best way I can explain his
powers would be to say that he is an
incomplete version of blue Marvel an T
man has all the same abilities as
Brashear but his control over them is
not as acute and his molecular structure
is literally unstable now back to the
conversation at hand regarding Brashear
Stark Reed and Pym Hanks initial
question is that if for Shearer was
watching the world unfold following the
assassinations of Kennedy and Martin
Luther King jr. he had to notice that
the world was improving what came is
basically saying here is that Brashear
could have come back at any point in
time and despite what he might say about
having his choices limited at the end of
the day at least some part of his
isolation was voluntary however
according to rushiro his view is that
the President of the United States had
requested that he stepped down and that
in his mind defying every question the
President on that level would break the
law as the one thing that holds society
together and keeps anarchy from reigning
supreme and the eyes of Brashear main
the law is of the utmost importance now
returning to our discussion on the
attempted start to apologize for his
path actions of the United States and
its rejection by Brashear where Adam
leaves to take care of personal matters
this concept is discussed further by
Reid Tony and PIM where Hank doesn't
seem to grasp why it is the brashear
takes the attitude that he does Bravo
establishes Reid as the voice of reason
and does this by using the idea of
mutants as an example of how prejudice
still exists within the realm of Marvel
Comics what Reid tells us is that were
the Avengers or the Fantastic Four
operate to save the world whenever
they're successful in quelling a threat
they're lauded as heroes but when the
x-men perform the same act they're
shunned by humanity to read prior to the
birth of Franklin followed by valaria he
had never had any reason to pay any
attention to the affairs of mutants and
the issues that they faced in society
however because both his children are
mutants with incredible powers by way of
Franklin's ability to warp reality and
Valerius genius-level intellect the
issues faced by mutants came into full
swing and so what Griffo is doing here
is making an analogy by comparing the
position of Reid before and after the
birth of his children to the position of
America only the advent of nationwide
media what I mean here is that during
the time of regional news the racial
issues in the United States were only
really known by intelligence
organizations under the government and
individuals residing in the areas whose
issues were most prevalent however
following the advent of nationwide news
families on one side of the country
could see what was happening on the
other side and as a result the totality
of racism in the United States was
thrown into view for the world to see
leading to a massive upheaval regarding
how American citizens viewed the nation
as a whole
now picking back up with bashir we
transitioned to his underwater fortress
and the Mariana Trench within the
Atlantic Ocean as the largest cavern in
the world and deep enough to house Mount
Everest with room to spare the trench
was a perfect location for blue Marvel's
base of operations and that the only
person who would have been able to
access it would have been named the
Submariner in greeting his old friend
this particular moment is very important
for several reasons the firs is that it
goes towards establishing how long
Brashear had operated as a superhero and
that named one had predated Brashear but
the two of them were extremely close
friends the second is that because the
two were friends
this establishes that in the eyes of
name were Brashear was an honorable man
which is something really found and that
name are pretty much hates everyone else
what we're also told is that regarding
his physical strength
Brashear is on par with both for and The
Incredible Hulk sowing that stated by
Namor and that when he and Bashir had
first met the two had fought one another
deuce namers belief that Russia was
simply invading his oceans the final
reason why the encounter between the two
is so important is due to the fact that
Namor actually s wages were sheer from
abandoning the Avengers and leaving them
to their own devices and intimidated the
anti man we're Beshear voices his
irritation over the nature of politics
and that he was previously asked to step
down but is now being asked to come back
even after learning that he spent his
whole life being monitored Namor uses
his experience fighting among the
invaders to provide a measure of
perspective what Namor says here is that
when he fought alongside Captain America
Bucky Barnes and Jim Hammond during
World War two he was also fighting
alongside what we referred to as Red
Tails now the Red Tails was a nickname
for pilots who painted the tails of
their planes red but the official name
for this group was a Tuskegee Airman as
african-americans fighting during World
War two the Tuskegee Airmen were a real
world element in society but because
African Americans were looked down upon
during this time the Tuskegee Airmen
were considered unintelligent and
largely treated as cannon fodder however
in the eyes of named work they were the
true embodiment of bravery and that
through it all they never turned their
backs on a fight were always the first
ones in and the last ones out using this
as a platform name what makes the case
that regardless of the conflict faced by
any one man there's always a choice to
be made regarding whether or not to act
and there will always be evil in the
world as a result those with the power
to confront that evil have a
responsibility to do so even if it flies
in the face of everything that they
believe and this logic is based solely
on the idea that should they not act the
evil of individuals in the world would
reign supreme and so taking the words of
Namor to heart for sure Dawn's as blue
marvel uniform with the intention of
returning to read Stark and pin and Ally
himself and their efforts to defeat the
anti man however before you can achieve
this counter makes is returned to
confront Adam for the first time since
her last encounter in the 1960s
now what Griffo does here is provide us
with the final piece of the back
story between sims and Brashear what we
learn here is that following the
experiment that gave them their powers
sims had somehow we materialized after
which he'd been taken to Breshears
underwater facility where Sims initially
greeter Brashear as a friend Sims was
informed that he had been in a coma for
a month furthermore after analyzing his
molecular structure Brashear came to the
conclusion that Sims molecules were
essentially breaking down in the atomic
level meaning that he appeared to be
dying
however for Sims the end of his
existence as a normal human and rebirth
through the power of antimatter made him
mentally unstable and to his insanity he
had come to the conclusion that
society's racism and Prejudice needed to
be eliminated to make way for utopia
sorts even if it required the
destruction of all life at the same time
where Bashir tries to reason with Sims
and recalling some of the get-togethers
that their families had shared with the
two becoming godfather to the others
children in the end Sims came to the
belief that Brashear had stolen his
family away from him however atom
counters this by stating that the
instability of Sims put not just society
but his own family in danger as such
pressure hid Sims family away under the
belief that he could reason with Sims
and restore him to normalcy furthermore
Brashear tries to help Sims understand
that the world isn't the way that it
used to be and while there will always
be prejudice in the world as his human
nature the landscape of Obon racism is
no longer an issue and that people are
more acceptable than they were before
but despite all this reasoning in the
end Sims believes that brashears
willingness to give society a chance to
demonstrate the steps is taken towards
acceptance is an inherent weakness and
that if Brashear has truly allied
himself with humanity that he's just as
guilty as everyone else and so as this
issue comes to a close
Sims attached for sheer knocking him
unconscious in the process and uses the
opportunity to continue his campaign
against humanity and his goal of
eliminating all life on the planet Earth
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and let me
know what you guys think about this
issue so far and I will catch you guys
later peace